um
but from what we're hearing it's going
to be a very small bonnaroo
and i was thinking about that as well i
go back to 2016 and part of the reason
you know ken weinstein who is the media
person and and has become a friend of
the show and
and was on our show by the way who
actually coined who coined the phrase
never not great basic
i see what you did there
it kind of kind of hurt a little bit
i'm going to have to prove it arnold i'm
going to have to go back and document
show receipts
but who did coin the phrase never not
great from 2016 which was the smallest
crowd ever
in uh you know what were going on 20
years it was great and it's partly
because everybody that is there wants to
be there and that makes a huge
difference about this festival yes true
you know we've all been to we've all
been to events where you know the
numbers could be good but it was still
there
i mean i i had an absolute
blast in 2016. it was one of it was the
of all the the boundaries i it's got to
be my top three i mean if not
if not my favorite year that we've had
so the crowd size is not going to be a
problem um but yeah to your point i know
i know this information is out there
because sponsors are starting to to
share it but
i mean i didn't hear 35k
i heard 25k
and
when sponsors hear 35k the reason why
they're hearing that number is because
they're being told a number so it'll
justify the paycheck or the justify the
check that they're about to write so
whatever you hear a sponsor say
uh subtract a little bit of a fraction
out of that because they're
overestimating for sponsors to make them
feel as though their money is worthwhile
to be spent with bonnaroo i was told 25k
and the next day i heard less than 30.
so whatever that means to you
um it to me it means the things that we
saw in 2016 are back there the fences
moved in the the spaces got smaller so
it didn't feel so vast and empty but
more importantly for those who have been
to exit 111 taco berry it's gonna feel a
lot like that yes
i was about to ask what was the numbers
for exit 111 because this feels like
this is about the attendance for exit
111
and it they did shrink it a bit they
brought cenaru in tighter uh they had
some of the campgrounds closed so it
didn't feel as empty right but it was
definitely smaller
i mean that's but most of those people
never went to bottoms yeah they didn't
know exactly that and that's the thing
that uh brad and i reminded ourselves
you know after 2016. i mean when we got
there for media day and noticed that how
how closed in the fence was on the the
wet stage area it was like you know
mind-blowing and then
the people who've never been would have
no idea so what's the big deal you know
it still felt like a very good large
festival bands were great yep everything
by the time you're there you're not
gonna give a damn that's only twenty
five thousand people right now you're
not gonna in fact you're gonna love it
you're gonna love the fact that there's
no lines for bathrooms and no lines for
showers and you know you're gonna be
able to get right up front you're gonna
get but i will but i will say
i mean just just
with all the experience that you have on
this farm i really weren't worried that
there's going to be
7 000 people for the stevie nicks show
come sunday
i mean it does that's really sad that
question
you know what and there's
as we've said many many times there's
nothing worse than an empty room i mean
even if it's a you know
if if it's a room that holds ten and
only two show up two is still a good
number for some events but it feels yeah
i mean taco you're there is your
question was how many people were at
exit 111 by their accounts it was 25k
and that was with
that's about that that sounds about half
of the
um square footage
so you know they're they're
now is that is that
i got a follow-up question is that
ticket sold or is that attendance
because when you roll in yeah vendors uh
oh attendant so vendors volunteers
uh workers yeah you can get to 35k get
closer to that yeah you can get to 35k
okay um yeah but
and the other thing too is is roundabout
now it's not like you're going to be
getting um an extra i don't know 20 000
tickets being sold you know no you're
not gonna get a lot of walk up at an
event like this
um i do wonder
um
you know they're still doing the load in
on tuesday and wednesday
which was a good idea uh on on paper and
i don't know no way that they can change
that now there's no way no i can't
change it but the reason was they were
gonna be you know trying to figure out
how to get 90 000 people into a 700 acre
farm
uh you know without long lines and all
that long delays and all that so
um i have no idea how many people signed
up for tuesday load in or wednesday load
in
uh as we look at the schedule thursday
music starts around four
so you know if you come in on tuesday at
what time you've got a good
two and a half full days of
no you know play
play bonnaroo pr for a second um what do
you think the reason is for the light
attendance this year
i mean go i'm not first playing play pr
member of
bonnaroo
um
if i'm them
i'm going to say pretty much what we've
said there are a lot of choices
people have made their choices maybe
adding that extra day
is not what people wanted maybe it's the
economy maybe we're coming out of
the
pandemic
now i mean i would spend more time in
and color it better than i'm coloring it
right now
but i i think those are all legit and i
think those are what they're going to
say they're they're not going to say
it's a lineup
you know because
they're going to say it's always it's
never not great it's still going to be
great it's always a fun time it's a time
for community
well to be fair a lot of things that you
said are actually true you know not only
is the the economy really tough we're
coming out of a
we're coming out of a a
pandemic where people are making
different choices about where they're
spending their money and they're being
they're having to be very very
uh specific with the things that they
choose to do not just with their dollars
but with their time
and you know uh it's not like all the
other festivals are blowing up and um
blowing the doors off the place there
are a few spaces where they're doing
really well
um i i'd like to know what the hangout
number ended up being over the over the
past weekend but you know lollapalooza
hasn't sold out yet they anticipate
they're going to sell it acl sold out in
a day when we were young sold out
multiple times but other than that are
you really seeing
a lot of a lot of movement on the big
scale i don't know what coachella ended
up um doing but did i hear that they
sold out i don't i don't think i did
maybe i may rush you said shaky knees
was great right big crowds
shaking these felt like it had a big
crowd it didn't feel any smaller than
last year yeah but yeah that's the only
two years i've been but because it's a
city festival and it's so much easier to
access and so much easier for locals to
to be a part of um you know bonus
becomes a yes bottom becomes difficult
and becomes hard to
yeah it becomes a hard yeah
shaky knees
had a great lineup too
yeah i i mean what
going back to the earlier question what
does happen if the 2020 lineup is this
year's lineup i i don't i mean
that was a heck of a lineup it's hard to
imagine that we at least don't double
whatever the bonnaroo number is
i do think that it's a very good point
barry is that they uh
it never ends up being about the lineup
and
there are i i understand i'm telling you
until it does i would argue i think that
has done such a great job of being post
lineup right they've they've figured out
a way to create an incredible
um atmosphere that is not line up
dependent well you know
maybe we're entering into a world
maybe we have we've entered to a world
where things are different and the
lineup is going to be very line-up
dependent now what you're asking
somebody to do is a big
it's a load of effort to do this over
the course of a few days and
you know people's options are wider and
faster and closer
but you you said earlier yourself next
year they come back you know
the the ones that are going want to go
right i mean let's we all agree on that
right i think that what we said this
isn't a this it's never uh it's never a
halfway right there's there is i feel
like there was a comment i feel like
there was a comment uh a few years ago
when we said
when it was 60 000 people for lcd sound
system and pearl jam and dead and
company i think
we had i
i feel like i'm remembering this
correctly
well
30 000 is the base
you're never gonna get less than thirty
thousand because
um if half of the crowd or new
bonnaroovians and new people to the
festival uh thirty
thirty thousand half of sixty was i
really do think like 30 is their
drop dead base number
and so long as they get there they're
going to be okay
okay and so that was i guess kind of
where i was going so those 30 show up
and have you know another good time and
they're going to tell a friend and bring
a friend and
you know maybe next year's lineup comes
out early and it's it's amazing and some
of these other ones as we've said you
know how many of them survive
i i
i really do feel like this is a
transition year where we're going to see
some go away and some survive well
i don't don't get too crazy with that
barry because you got you'll get you
know conspiracy theorists who see
uh the state of tennessee i'm sorry not
the state of tennessee what's the state
of tennessee in the city of manchester
uh putting the screws to bonnaroo and
bonnaroo fighting back and saying well
we don't need to do this here
um so could
you start saying stuff like that it's
going to get people
you know a little rocky it's going to
make them feel a little itchy
could be could very well be there could
be a lot of things going on behind doors
we don't know about but what we do know
is it's
live nation right which c3 has
plenty of money and
they do own the farm so they're you know
we would like to think committed
it's not you know it's not a small thing
but you're right
they're big enough too they could walk
away and yeah yeah i mean it's it i
they it's not
the way that it was told to me i think
we've said this before it's not like
bonnaroo makes them a lot of money
i mean it makes them enough to keep
going and it is a valuable part of the
whole asset
and and part of the whole you know
structure and you know but it's not like
they're blowing the doors off making a
ton of money here they have a just a
shitload of overhead
that a city festival just doesn't have
to
have to engage in